a former catcher for the Seattle
Mariners traded in his baseball mitt for
a chance to help others
Mike Marja mo grinded it out in the
minors for seven years before finally
landing his dream job in the big leagues
but in a letter this month the 29 year
old announced he was retiring to focus
on supporting people battling eating
disorders it's an issue that Marge amaz
struggled with himself
Jamie yuccas spoke to him about his big
decision it took a lifetime of work for
Mike Marge amah to reach his dream come
home run Mike it's pretty cool it's um
it's surreal but just 15 games into his
career with the Seattle Mariners Marge
ma called it quits what else can I do
like what kind of impact can we have as
he look toward the future
Marge Emma couldn't shake his past he
once suffered from a severe eating
disorder that started when he was just
12 did I look normal sure but the things
that were going on inside my head
weren't normal no normal kid would strep
trash bags to his body and put on
multiple layers of sweat shirts and
sweatpants and go turn on the showers
and steam and ride till they pass out
why were you doing it because I thought
that would help me achieve a goal
what was that goal I wanted to look like
a male model I was like what how can I
be that guy right how can I have a
six-pack so I was like well common sense
if I work out a ton and I I'll get big
and strong and if I don't eat anything I
won't get fat like voila I'm there as a
high school athlete Marge Emma endured a
cycle of anorexia and bulimia
he hit his eating habits until his
disease revealed itself my mom and made
this big elaborate Thanksgiving dinner
and I put there's like 3 almonds and two
carrots on my plate when he finally
sought help he sat out sports for a year
and was the only man in treatment many
guys feel a tremendous amount of shame
about reaching out for help Claire misko
runs the National Eating Disorders
Association or Neda we know that boys
and men are subjected to an onslaught of
images and messages about what's healthy
and how to be fit and what's the perfect
body
and that is having an impact Nita claims
of the 30 million who suffer from a
variety of eating disorders 10 million
are men 10 million men I truly think
that those numbers are off higher and I
would say I don't think I know that
Marge OMA is now helping others to
recover he's become an ambassador for
Nita speaking out and raising awareness
how awesome is it now that I get to
voluntarily walk away from something
that I love so much to do something that
I'm passionate about too
I want to be someone that people look at
you mean they go or they look on my
tombstone they go this guy just wanted
to make a difference he just when he was
there he just loved life for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas kai yuccas California Bravo
to him for speaking out that way those
guys don't do that it's gonna help a lot
of people today